what's going on guys
al Rudnick here at San Diego comic-con
2019 and be here means one thing
time for me to go around and say a lot
of stupid stuff to cosplayers it's kind
of a con today oh we're just a few
clovers
[Music]
ah what's your name
that's great tiny Batman
can I meet tiny Bruce Wayne I don't know
who that is
stranger things make some noise
making love to a giant Megalodon I'm
having sex with a giant Megalodon
mountain what up dude I see your
reanimated Jaime Lannister okay can you
give us a couple of classic Joker lines
I'm not wait hold on that's a negatory
seriously
how you doing kicking it with your
brother I'm Sansa oh four two does
anyone have a better story than grand
Brienne has a better story than we're in
I think everybody does all of them
although everybody well I say long live
you say bran the broken long live
Brandon broken yeah that's I'm talking
about Tony Stark's jewelry if I'm not
gonna cut why did you come to comic-con
and break the room down with this for
that exact reaction you're doing how do
you think Deadpool should be integrated
into the MCU no that's the wrong
question how should the MCU be
integrated into destiny oh I would love
to be in the spider-verse you guys help
me come up with my personal spider-verse
character
would you like to see these
well I could sneeze webs spider sneeze
shoot your webs achoo hot shoe I like
your style is there any way I could
borrow your goon for a little bit ever
you rent out your good do you know where
the Schneider cut is can you smell it
where's the Schneider cut it's in a lot
of fanboys dreams and I don't think it's
coming anywhere else but there you just
burned the fanboy we can forth into Zack
Snyder and find the Snyder cut no bus
are you a little bit more interested in
the Burton cut if there is one I found
it but is there one can you break a
comic-con exclusive here today I don't
think there's one what would you do for
the Snyder cut okay
oh I'll be buried under the same pile as
the cartridges
oh good answer in truth I wouldn't do
anything for the Schneider cut I'm gonna
go in the name of the mother in the name
of the warrior and the name of the
Father
arise Sir Hal of screen junkies Wendy's
Widow with my process my spoons and
nothing's better than taking a nice
salty fried pig into a frosty
YUM so I see you're dressed as
everyone's favorite superhero Rocket Man
is there a twerking contest tonight I
hope so
[Music]
now that you taught me to floss dance
can I teach you how to floss sure take
it like this
oh yeah there's some good Comic Con in
those teeth Comic Con let your freak
flag fly
give us some classic Spaceballs lines of
course my character doesn't have any of
the memorable lines I didn't ask for
excuses I asked for classic Spaceballs
line can you give us that a classic line
sure I can use the force but where my
nugs sure I can use the force but where
are my nubs how about that famous Toy
Story for catchphrase Geppetto I want to
be a real boy hey babe give me a ring
when your parents aren't home get away
from me with that Acura I'm an Audi man
screw your Acura I'm an Audi man sorry
didn't pay for Hulu next month it's
cancelled proactive work for me and it
worked for you too nobody better lay a
finger on my Butterfinger
it's Brienne of Tarth not Wayne and
Garth can someone rustle up some hot
dudes in these woods dark helmet was
played by Rick Moranis oh if you want a
smaller helmet you can be in Honey I
Shrunk the helmet what do you think
about that huh run fire that was the
appropriate response if you've been here
before you know that comic-con is where
the true fans come to celebrate pop
culture now I'm gonna find out if they
have any cool fan theories about some
questions that I've really been
wondering about
[Music]
will we find out or won't we who raised
parents are but are you like me I wanted
to know who Luke's parents are you have
any theories on who Luke's parents are
eyes on the prize
we know who Luke's parents are oh okay
okay tell me
Vader aren't Luke's parents Anakin
Skywalker and Padme do you think we
might find out for sure in Episode nine
no I think that's already been answered
again your opinion not mine
I think we found that out in Episode
three Anakin nice try
keep your fan theories on reddit buddy
cold rises Skywalker yeah well I think
they mean Rey Oh
Luke I'm your father okay what's that
now
I'm at the Vikings battle-ax training
they're going to let me throw an axe
I've signed a waiver don't you know I'm
Loco yes finally
up and around right
yeah release the site but I wasn't
humped enough as a child
my name is Inigo Montoya you killed my
father prepare to die Game of Thrones is
off the air the world belongs to bite
head book-smart should have done better
at the box
[Music]
[Applause]
I don't want to brag but after all these
years to come to comic-con I've gotten
pretty good at comic-con ik so right now
I'm going to show you everything you
need to do at comic-con in under a
minute
this is con in sixty Seconds you've
gotta wait in the line getting a picture
with Harley Quinn is a must you gotta
have fun with your favorite movie quotes
you are the Droid I'm looking for ya
gotta hang with some Deadpool's you have
to chug some mustard this one might just
be me gotta wait more lines gotta get
some celebrity signings you're the real
mr. Spock right sure kid gotta buy a
t-shirt there a skull buy a comic just
kidding no one buys comics at comic-con
anymore okay I'm running at a time I
need to find some excuse of content do
you guys have any exclusive content I
don't know what that means
hey did you take any videos on your
phone this weekend
yeah this dog that's exclusive content
and counts get a mild case of heatstroke
[Music]
yeah I did it now it is time for a
well-earned nap this comecon ever thank
you for watching screen junkies all the
hell Rudnik hit me up on twitter bye-bye